make America great again in Volcom
Slogan von Donald Trump hält mich
krank für Paul Horton Tobias
Tesla Logan Vitomir Stanga Sheikh Taqi
Ashville Sohn Ownership Eagles und Einladung
zur Brighton-Reaktion Erin Site-Geist
Pass enorm gesaugt Mark Leela Danish
kann sicher im Studio in Berlin sein  Vicki sagt,
es sei Professorin für Englisch an
der Columbia University in New York
– sogar Silent Vision Alta und die
New York Times lesen einige Lumen in Philly und
setzen
Saina Kritik an ihrer Identität als
politisch demokratische indische Aktivistin
von Donald Trump eine Reifsocke
Operanden wenige Hit, um einen Knopf zu bekommen
FCB-Common Helena gut, hier zu sein ja
le laasa hartnäckig seine Füße als Reaktion
Eric vereiste Feindin Allison irgendwie gut - nein
- nein, es sind sehr schlechte Nachrichten, weil Sie wissen, dass
die Natur der Reaktion darin besteht, zu denken, dass
Sie es sind  Sie haben nach einem Bruch in der
Geschichte gelebt und wollen unbedingt zurück, und
was mit Revolutionären passiert,
konzentriert sich zu sehr auf die zukünftigen Reaktionäre
sind zu sehr auf die Vergangenheit konzentriert und in dieser
Zeit wird die Aufmerksamkeit nicht
auf unsere Gegenwart gerichtet und versucht,
all die Komplikationen unserer
heutigen Lebensweise und unsere politischen
Probleme zu verstehen, insbesondere mit der Weltwirtschaft
und dem Rest, also gibt es eine Art
Flucht davor  intellektuelle Verantwortung Ich fühle mich
sehr ehrenhaft Mode gegenüber einem
reaktionären straffen Caston ist Unehrlichkeit,
die jedem möglichen
reaktionären Moment vorangeht edn - hat jemand banco
nacional
über Pam ist die Mission gestartet?
was sie teilen, ist zunächst einmal eine Vorstellung von
Geschichte, sie denken über
Politik in Begriffen der Geschichte, nicht in
Begriffen der menschlichen Natur, sagen wir, und sie
haben ein Bild von der Geschichte, dass es
eine Zeit gab, in der die Dinge so liefen, und ein
gesundes
in einem gesunden  Weg und dann gab es eine
Pause, es gab einen Moment, in dem
alles auseinanderbrach und was auch
immer danach passiert ist, es war das
Ergebnis davon  was da so für die
Nationalen passierte von den Problemen beginnen in der
Geschichte die sie jetzt erzählen mit Einwanderung
Einwanderung und die
Kulturrevolution der 60er Jahre hat zu einer wie auch zu
Kriminalität geführt hat zu Problemen in den Schulen geführt und
alles andere und so weiter  des
Bruchs, der in den 60er und 70er Jahren
all diese Probleme geschaffen hat, die es erfordern, dass wir
auf die Welt zurückblicken, die
vor diesem Bruch existierte. Der islamische Fall ist
ziemlich ähnlich, den die Islamisten im Gegensatz
zu ernsthaften islamischen Islamwissenschaftlern
im 19. Jahrhundert
glauben  Dass eine durchgehende islamische
Tradition durch den Modernisierungskolonialismus gebrochen worden war
und auch gerade
durch die Aufklärung, dass Länder
anfingen, moderne Wissenschaften entwickeln zu wollen,
brachte all das Übrige mit sich, so dass alle
zeitgenössischen Probleme in muslimischen
Gesellschaften für die Islamisten
darauf zurückgehen  war eine Abkehr vom
Scharia-Gesetz und der Westen bewegte in seinem
Lied die Aufnahme der Kita der Ziya-Klasse, die
keinen Eintrag von de Gu benötigt  iche
die sitze auf einer nasa eine anständige tasche eine
bedeutsame karuppu freude an der marke der
clownstab eine gemeinsame höhe ziel eine
anständige reaktion luft innen gegossen ein
synonym eingegeben setzt ein schloss am ofen
siehe den ganzen nachmittag stylist ein reaktionär
ängstlich mein name ist gesellschaft farbe  ein
tapferer ein trostloser sogar durchschnittlicher
Haqqanis, um die konservative
Wissenschaftlerin Frau zu treffen.  de mia clan
ja, ich denke, man muss zwei paare
im auge behalten, also denken sie an konservative und
liberale oder was wir in den vereinigten staaten liberale nennen
, wäre hier so etwas wie
sozialdemokraten,
was sie trennt, ist, dass sie unterschiedliche
bilder von der menschlichen natur und der
beziehung haben  von Individuen zur Gesellschaft
Konservative sehen die Gesellschaft als etwas
, das sich kontinuierlich im Laufe der Zeit entwickelt Wir
als Individuen sind eigentlich Produkte
unserer Gesellschaft, eine Art Instanzen unserer
Gesellschaften, und nicht freie Individuen,
und dass ein gesunder sozialer Wandel entsteht,
wenn Sie die Traditionen an diese
Individuen weitergeben und wenn  Es wird
Veränderungen geben, die kontinuierlich und langsam sein werden.
Liberale beginnen mit dem Individuum und
dem Individuum als Träger von Rechten.
Sie wurden von der Gesellschaft als
Produkt eines Vertrags zwischen Menschen konzipiert,
die sich aus diesem Grund
nicht zusammengeschlossen haben  jede Art von
historischer Katastrophe oder ähnlichem implizieren
, sind sie zwei rivalisierende Bilder dessen, was
wir als Menschen sind  n Individuen und
kollektiv das Revolutionäre und das
Romantische und die Reaktion, da haben sich
beide Dinge im 19. Jahrhundert wirklich entwickelt,
sie haben sich zusammen entwickelt, und
was sie mit dem Revolutionär
und dem Reaktionär teilen, ist der Sinn
für Geschichte, den ich gerade beschrieben
habe  es gab eine Pause oder dass es
eine Pause geben wird, also hat ein
Revolutionär diesen Glauben, dass eine
bestimmte Art von politischer Aktivität
zu einer Pause führen wird, nach der alles gut sein
wird,
oder wenn die Revolutionen bereits stattgefunden haben
, muss diese Revolution
fortgesetzt werden  und diejenigen, die nicht dabei
sind, müssen jetzt davon befreit werden
, dokkum, das ist ein Volvo von Donald Trump Ryan,
macht Amerika wieder großartig, als au s vamanos
es que estaban, also will Assad 2008
euch als schelmischen Sube Valve als
konservativen Schamanen haben  Reaktion ein
absoluter Tiefgang in meinem Bereich und ich
verstehe Englisch verleugnet garniert
Künstler ein kornisches Geräusch, also war es
Ausstrahlung, ja, du weißt schon, l  et's make
America great great again von Reagan
im Norden
vom Hotties in Volvo Video Gentleman
hätte genau ich nicht
mit einer Nominierung eines
interessanten Essens garniert Sie bringen das zur Sprache
Es ist außerhalb der Vereinigten Staaten nicht sehr bekannt
, dass das so ist  den Fall und
sie meinten es auf unterschiedliche Weise. Ich denke,
mmm-hmm, Reagans Botschaft war hoffnungsvoll, dass
Amerikaner süchtig nach Hoffnung sind, und man
muss ihnen irgendwie eine hoffnungsvolle
Vision ihrer Zukunft vermitteln, und was Reagan
meinte, war meiner Meinung nach nicht, dass wir
zurückkehren müssten  Dinge, wie sie in der
Vergangenheit waren, aber wenn wir die Dinge richtig machen, werden
wir so großartig sein, wie wir in der Vergangenheit waren
, aber wir müssen nicht
mit Trompeten zu den Dingen zurückkehren, eine Rückkehr, es geht
darum, alles rückgängig zu machen  Dieser Schaden
, der angerichtet wurde, denn was
mit reaktionärem Denken einhergeht, ist nicht nur,
dass es eine Pause gegeben hat, sondern dass es
einer Apokalypse bedarf, um die
Dinge wieder in Ordnung zu bringen.
Sie wissen, dass Heidegger sagte, nur ein Gott
kann uns jetzt retten und t  Der Reaktionär
glaubt, dass nur eine Apokalypse uns jetzt retten kann,
und wenn Sie sogar mit
intelligenten, gebildeten Trump-Wählern sprechen,
sagen sie oft alle dasselbe, nämlich
dass wir gewählt haben, weil wir die Dinge zerstören wollten,
das ist eine apokalyptische
Mentalität, die aus der Reaktion hervorgeht wurde
angegriffen  des ganzen Liedes
, das mir so am nächsten ist, Feld über den Iran, unter dem es in den Ohren gesprochen wird
, nämlich Sigmund
Parminder, der es sagt - schau, sie sind
leichter, schneller, ehrliches Zeichen lässt uns
Policia lesen - Connie, sorry, oh nein,
Schatz, ich brauche einen, den ich wünsche  Thomas zieht es
auf Utopia unendlich Irisch Wette in Skagen
Strumpfhosen von einem Karim - Sonia
gibt es 10 von diesen pro Tag Buchanan
Jurgen van der Utopia die aktuelle US
genannte Annette Seite Alton oh hey mridu
zusammen Baron Person ihre Initiale es ist ein
Politiker Australien kommt
Alice bewegt sich am nächsten zu einem anderen
Systemende und dort ist Arkansas, zumindest
ich weiß, dass es sich um eine riesige Auster handelt, nicht um eine
ultraheiße Nische, an der
Isha beteiligt ist
vergangener Dämon in Vollstreckungsposten nicht
Sie wissen ungefähr hundert Kaffee auf einer
Uzi, es ist nicht das Ventil von Donald Trump,
ja ja, genau
, aber was an einer
Art Enttäuschung interessant ist, die Sie gerade
erwähnt haben, ist, dass revolutionäre
Hoffnungen immer enttäuscht werden können, so wie Sie es getan haben  Eine
Revolution, von der Sie erwarten, dass sich die Dinge ändern.
Nostalgie ist unwiderlegbar, denn
was Sie tun können, ist zu sagen, dass der
Grund, warum die Dinge nicht funktionieren, nicht darin besteht, dass
wir die Revolution nicht hatten, sondern dass
wir nicht weit genug zurückgegangen sind und so
Die Leute behalten eine Vorstellung von der Vergangenheit, weil
sie das Gefühl haben, die Vergangenheit sei bereits geschehen.
Wir sind Revolutionäre, haben eine Fantasie von
der Zukunft, und daher ist es viel einfacher,
in die Pedale zu treten, um politische Nostalgie zu verkaufen, als
es um zukünftige politische Utopie zu gehen. Ich
denke, im Moment, ja, tatsächlich eine Läsion
agonistischer islamistischer Kunst und für nationale
Feldhockeygeister auf Chaos in der
Liga nun Honig gibt es interesante Totems
für die Schwanzranch wie in Paris für
2015 mit dem IME plötzlich  Akhtar ist ein Mann
in der Kunst, der in unseren Caucus
eindringt und Wasser auf staubige Multiventile gießt. Unser
Fleisch ist Wahnsinn, jetzt hat er auch die
Südbriten dazu gebracht, instrumental zu sein,
sogar die Politikerin von Sally
Olga Connery bei den Inselfeinden zu begrenzen, sie
hatte Tonnen von uns, die Frau folgen  Der vegane Code
beginnt mit der muslimischen Ishe-Wunde über Obama
und dem rückgängig gemachten Denken, aber über den
gnädigen Frank. Ich werde östlich von der
Schneide All's Fair Woman gegen Lee
Malvo enden. Ja, ich lebte dort, als
es passierte, und ich sah, wie sich beide Dinge
nacheinander entwickelten  Ein anderes und seltsamerweise
eines der Bücher, das
diese
französische Nostalgie am stärksten ausdrückte und katalysierte, war su misión the
well back, und es wurde
am Tag des Bombenanschlags auf Charlie Hebdo veröffentlicht, und
von diesem Tag an
entwickelten sich beide Dinge
parallel  Je mehr wir über
die Motive der Mörder verstanden, die
sehr nostalgisch waren, ohne viel ohne viel
Bildung, desto mehr verstanden wir darüber
, desto mehr ac  Einige französische
reaktionäre Rechte haben sich entwickelt, um zu
erklären, wie wir das in Frankreich bekommen haben, also war für
mich diese parallele Entwicklung einfach ein
faszinierendes Leben
.
Apokalypse
und sein Organversagen Colitis die
Frühlingsmelodien als Polytechnikum Falun Dafa ich
Rondo Ich bin der Vater mein Wein
der Brandstifter ungebrochen de Guiche die
Filme unser Geschäft oder Heineken positive
Beziehung auch halten die Schlangen Türkisch ein
Sonntag Miyazaki missin unaufrichtig b-
dumme Antwort sicher  Ich meine, es ist immer
einfach, Erwartungen in unserem Privatleben zu wecken,
nicht nur in der Politik, und
wenn wir dann heiraten und
enttäuscht sind, dass wir Kinder haben, werden wir
richtig enttäuscht, aber
wenn man die Geschichte auf diese Weise betrachtet, passiert etwas anderes als
das Drama  scheint nicht
nur dramatischer zu sein, sondern Sie haben tatsächlich keine
Werkzeuge, um dies zu beeinflussen. Wenn Sie jedoch wissen, dass eine
Ehe nicht ideal ist,
können Sie zu einer Therapie gehen oder an Ihrer
Ehe arbeiten oder was auch immer, aber was tun Sie,
wenn Sie in der USA leben?  Im 21. Jahrhundert
und vor Jahrhunderten gab es diesen Bruch in der islamischen
Geschichte, es gibt sehr
wenig, was man praktisch tun kann, und deshalb
muss man über radikale Dinge nachdenken,
und dann ma  Wenn Sie wissen, dass Sie
sich diesen Dingen verpflichten, und sich die Dinge trotzdem
nicht ändern, geraten Sie in einen Kreislauf von
Enttäuschung und Radikalisierung,
was wir im politischen Islam als Manie sehen. Die Politiker
in den USA sind einen Moment lang
eine
Illusion  Angekniffen in Informationen von, die es
geschafft haben, die Wertschätzung und Textur der
Eltern als Geige zu lesen, um
Nemi-Chan-Cast-Kommentare zur Musik der neuen
Zeit zu lesen, ist Oktober Agnes im Westen,
Mo Cotton Davia für Tante Watley,
Mohandas Trump, da ein Hottentotten-SV
eingeladen wurde  zu vitatree Muhammads okinawanischer
Identitätspolitik Ich habe ihn weggelassen,
einige TV-Fergan zu drehen, weil es auf Minda
Hydratation bestimmte
Ära und Pathos gibt, die ich
sehe
Das Missverständnis besteht darin,
dass der Untertitel des Artikels besagt,
dass dies der Grund für den Verlust von Hillary Clinton
in meinem Artikel war, sondern dass die
Identitätspolitik wirklich
für 30 Jahre Demokratisierung verantwortlich war  Politik,
die sich nicht auf die Nation und das, was
wir gemeinsam haben, und ein gemeinsames Projekt konzentriert
, um beispielsweise den Reaganismus zu bekämpfen
, sondern auf die Forderungen und die
Sorgen und Empfindlichkeiten bestimmter
Gruppen, diese Empfindlichkeiten und diese
Sorgen sind echt, aber durch die Konzentration auf
kleine Gruppen  und nicht auf die Nation und
das Gefühl, dass die Nation ein
gemeinsames Schicksal
hat, hat die Bedeutung
der institutionellen Politik in den Vereinigten
Staaten und nicht nur der Bewegungspolitik aus den Augen verloren,
und es ist nicht nur so, dass die Erwähnung der
Identitätspolitik die Menschen dazu veranlasst hat, dafür zu stimmen
Trump, es war nicht so, dass wenn diese
Identitätspolitik Demokraten und Liberale im
Allgemeinen aus dem Geschäft herausgeholt hat, aus einem
Visionsgeschäft, wenn Sie so wollen, und sie stattdessen
diese Gruppen als immer
konkurrierende Forderungen gesehen haben, ist 20 Monogamie, die sich darüber
hinwegsetzt, dass etwas passiert, eine Art politische Mary
Mafia Nikki Minenschacht manchmal orientalischer
Schutz ja und es war nicht nur so, dass
diese kleinen Gruppen diesen kleinen
Kunden ELLs Witz haben  h bestimmte politische
Forderungen, aber was hat sich geändert,
und ich habe versucht,
das Geschoss zu beschreiben, denn damals gab es eine
Bewegung von der Identitätspolitik,
die als institutionelle
Politik dieser Klientelgruppen verstanden wird, hin zu einer
Identitätspolitik, bei der es um die Identität
des Einzelnen geht  Es wurde zu einer Politik
der Bedeutung, es geht um mich, meine Identität, wie
ich mich selbst definiere und
vom Rest der Gesellschaft anerkannt werden möchte, und
ich betreibe nur Politik in Bezug auf
Dinge, die beeinflussen, wie ich
mich selbst als Individuum verstehe, was es
sehr schwierig macht  Menschen
für ein gemeinsames Projekt zu engagieren Politik
hört nicht auf Moslem Devane und EEMA
vie de vivre wird bestritten altruistisch existiert
in der Twitter-Werbung von John F.
Nicht ich gegen
uns alle kann jedes Team mit dem Spielen beginnen, da
ich denke, das war heute Abend schmutzige Dunkelheit,
und wir sind Premium, es ist besonders Team,
ja, ja, und ein Teil davon ist t  Er hat das Gefühl,
dass es im Land kein „Wir“ gibt, sondern
dass es nur verschiedene Gruppen sind, und wenn wir von „Wir“
sprechen, ist das eine Tarnung dafür, dass
nur Weiße auf
amerikanischen Universitäten so sagen, zum Beispiel, wie
man das Wort „Wir“
ironischerweise ausspricht  wenn es so etwas nicht gibt
und das bedeutet, dass, wenn Menschen
außerhalb liberaler Kreise leiden
und sie suchen, dass die
Nation zusammenkommt, um ihnen zu helfen, nur wenn die
Republikaner eine Vision angeboten haben, es eine
schreckliche Vision ist, finden wir, dass Reagan
Vision hat nicht gehalten, was es versprochen hat,
aber zumindest war es eine Vision des Landes
, die die Menschen inspiriert, während die Demokraten
dort Weiße für das kritisieren, was
sie Schwarzen und allem anderen angetan haben,
was für uns in Bildung,
Film und Zivilgesellschaft wichtig ist  Wir
machen eine Abrechnung mit unserer Geschichte, aber
Politik ist Politik, du musst hinausgehen
und Menschen, die anders sind, davon überzeugen,
sich dir in einem gemeinsamen Projekt anzuschließen, aber dieser
Narzissmus sitzt besonders tief  y unter
den Jungen sind sie unfähig,
mit Menschen in Mittelamerika zu sprechen, und
kümmern sich außerdem nicht einmal darum - sie haben Verachtung für
sie, was kein Weg ist, Macht in der
Politik zu
gewinnen  Umfang außerhalb und Blockierung der einstigen und
zukünftigen Liberalen war es gelegentlich
Hammer oft herausragend, noch bevor wir
wissen, Hamartia Einstein Barmherzigkeit Dämonen, was
Common Law Sendero unterseeisch zu Desert
Moment böswillige Angriffe Politik ist eine
Norm Vistage Filme und Faschist Andrew
Solomon und Ramallah Stencil  Okay, ihr
inhärenter TEDTalk, aber ist Wertschätzung, sprach
nicht, es brauchte Identität, um mich vor Traurigkeit zu retten.
Die Schwulenrechtsbewegung postuliert eine
Welt, in der mein unfruchtbarer Sieg
Identitätspolitik immer an zwei
Fronten arbeitet, um Menschen mit
einem bestimmten Zustand oder einer bestimmten Eigenschaft stolz zu machen  und
die Außenwelt dazu zu bringen,
solche Menschen sanfter und freundlicher zu behandeln, das
sind zwei völlig getrennte Unternehmungen, aber
Fortschritt in z  Jede Sphäre hallt in
der anderen wider Identitätspolitik kann
narzisstische Menschen
nur deshalb preisen, weil es Menschen gibt, die
die Welt verengt haben und in
diskreten Gruppen mit unserer Empathie
füreinander funktionieren, aber richtig verstandene und
weise praktizierte Identitätspolitik
sollte unsere Vorstellung von dem, was sie ist, erweitern
um menschlich zu sein
Andrew Solomon Dichter am wenigsten von
Identitätspolitik oder auch heutiger
Politik fühlen sie sich geistig
aufgebläht war kein Scherz nein ich habe das noch nie
gesehen und es sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine
Antwort auf mein Buch, das sehr
interessant ist,
ich denke so  Um es zu erklären ist,
dass Amerika zwei
Revolutionen gleichzeitig durchmacht, eine ist eine
politische Revolution, die
von rechts und von unten kommt, und die ist
populistisch, es gibt eine andere Revolution
, die eine Kulturrevolution ist,
und bei dieser Revolution geht es um all die
Dinge, über die Andrew Sullivan gerade gesprochen hat
Ich habe gerade von Solomon gesprochen, und
das ist, dass Menschen Anerkennung und Anerkennung
brauchen  Akzeptanz in der Gesellschaft Die Veränderungen in meinem
Leben in
Bezug auf Mietverträge waren außergewöhnlich.
Ich meine, stellen Sie sich vor, dass vor 10 Jahren
niemand die Homo-Ehe sehr ernst genommen hat, oder vor
15 Jahren ist es eine große Veränderung in der
Weltgesellschaft, das sind alles gute Veränderungen, aber
diese Revolution wird geführt  von den kulturellen
Eliten kommt es nicht von unten und
es ist nicht demokratisch in dem Sinne, dass
niemand über dieses Recht abstimmen kann,
aber Hollywood, die Presse, das
Bildungswesen stimmt irgendwie zu, dass diese
neuen Werte gelehrt werden müssen
, das ist gut, das Problem ist, wenn überhaupt
Ihre Energien gehen in diese Kulturrevolution,
Sie achten nicht
auf wirklich konkrete Macht. Die andere Sache
ist, wenn Sie nur über diese
kulturellen Dinge sprechen und darüber, wie Menschen
getrennt werden, obwohl diese Dinge
wichtig sind, ist das Bild, das die Öffentlichkeit
von Ihnen bekommt, so  eine Partei oder eine politische
Gruppe, die sich nur um diese
und diese Leute kümmert, mm-hmm, und sich nicht
um die Nation als Ganzes oder Leute kümmert,
die es nicht sind  lang zu diesen Gruppen und so
gibt es eine tragische Wahl in
Bezug auf Energie und in Bezug auf Rhetorik
versus Lack, die Vicki Füller bekommen hat,
nämlich ein Logistikproblem, das darauf behindert ist,
also bestehen
wir auf der Türken wie Alice, wir bestehen unseren
Angriff  darin tief zu Hause dies einen
Moment im Studio, um auf den
Status t4g plötzliche Flaggenkanister von
Mahavira mr zu erheben.  Socken eBay und dr.  T's sind
in West Virginia Seat Watson-
Filmen in muslimischen Arabern direkt bei Connie entkommen,
obwohl nur das Theater von
Opiat auf dem Schlackenfalken das Problem eines
On-Shot-Essenz-Bremsmanövers öffnet, kleine
Eden-Theoretiker kritisch KBC, so richtig
gelesen, besitzen das verständnisvollste Kind
und Feinschmecker  Bidens Befehl gut, ich denke
, das stimmt, und ich denke, man muss
ein bisschen noch wichtiger wählen,
wenn ich diese Frage
von Leuten bekomme, die in Identitätspolitik involviert sind,
muss ich sie davon überzeugen, dass sie, wenn
sie der institutionellen Politik keine Aufmerksamkeit schenken,
sie  können
diese Gruppen in unseren Staaten nicht schützen,
weil im amerikanischen föderalen
Systemstaatsgesetz das 50-Staaten-
Staatsgesetz viele Dinge bestimmt, wenn Sie in einem
republikanischen Staat sind, der keine
Gesetze erlassen wird, damit Transgender-Personen
ihr eigenes Badezimmer oder ähnliches haben
keine Menge Aktivität  In Washington wird
sich das ändern, geben Sie ein sehr
konkretes Beispiel in einem Bundesstaat Iowa vor ein
paar Wochen der Legislatur  Wenn wir uns entschieden haben,
ab dem Moment
, in dem der Herzschlag des Fötus zu
hören war, eine illegale Abtreibung vorzunehmen, das sind ungefähr sechs Wochen, bevor die
meisten Frauen wissen, dass sie schwanger sind,
stellt der Staat die Tatsache in Frage, dass
wir in unserem Land ein verfassungsmäßiges Recht auf
Abtreibung haben, indem er Hillary wählt
Clinton hätte nicht geändert, dass der
Kongress nicht geändert hätte, dass der
einzige Weg, das zu ändern, darin besteht, dass Sie in der
Lage sein müssen, bei den Wahlen in Iowa nach Iowa zu gehen
und die Menschen zu überzeugen, die in
Iowa leben und in fast mehr als 80 % weiß sind
80% evangelisch, also musst du
einen Weg finden, diese Leute zu erreichen,
um deine eigenen Leute zu schützen, die in diesem Staat leben,
das ist der Punkt, an dem
Tatas Geld verschwunden ist, niemand, also nach
Sacramento, für mich ist kein Versuchsergebnis auf
der Leber, ein fühlender Finger zum
Alpha kann unsere Otesaga-
Sprache verstehen, die mir recht gegeben und streng
richtig ist. Ja, nun, ich möchte nicht andeuten,
und zu viele Leute denken, dass
es darum geht, unsere Augen
von einem Satz Gro zu nehmen  Ups und Konzentration auf eine
andere Gruppe Mein Punkt ist, dass die
Demokraten sich überhaupt nicht auf Gruppen konzentrieren müssen,
sondern vielmehr eine Vision von
der Art von Land artikulieren müssen, die sie
aufbauen wollen, und von welchen Prinzipien die
Reagan-Jahre, mit denen ich meine, ausgehen  1980
bis Donald Trump in dieser Ära war die
Vision des Landes, dass weniger
Regierung, desto besser, und wenn wir
weniger Regierung haben, wird es der Wirtschaft gut gehen
und es allen besser gehen und wir
gehören alle zu unseren Familien und unseren
Kirchen, aber so etwas gibt es nicht
Staatsbürgerschaft, die wirklich zählt,
anstatt diese Vision zu vergleichen, die die
Demokraten nicht hatten, und jetzt müssen sie
artikulieren, was für ein Land sie
schaffen wollen, damit die Menschen in all diesen
Gruppen sich diese Prinzipien ansehen und
sagen können, das bin ich in einem Moment siehe
affiliative ik  Smitty boom et cetera Z
kommt aus Amsterdam, hat genug gewonnen, aber
von Bellinos jetzt polizeilicher Wette auf ein Haus
hat uns Interessen nicht verborgen und süchtig gemacht
und ist sogar geboren und ist bei esa verdammt noch mal so
dran wie es ist  Phineas Torinis erste Reaktion
war in den USA das Gegenteil oder Zenzi parallel
und beginnende Energiephänomene in Opa,
was sehr interessant ist, dieses Buch ist
das erste Buch, das ich über Amerika geschrieben habe,
und ich hatte nicht erwartet, dass es
irgendwo übersetzt wird,
und es wird überall übersetzt  die
Welt, nicht nur in Europa, in
Lateinamerika, in Asien, in China,
Korea, an all diesen Orten, was ich
entdecke, ist, dass viele Länder nicht deshalb
so viel über die Vereinigten Staaten lernen wollen, weil sie
so viel
Angst haben
identität heute wer sind wir was
meinen wir jetzt wenn man auf deutsch
via schaaf sagt und fragt wer ist via und
angesichts von globalisierung und massiven
bewegungen von menschen und internet
wissen die leute nicht, was es heißt zu a zu
gehören  Die Gesellschaft ist für sie kein Ort mehr,
aber es zeigt sich in verschiedenen Ländern auf unterschiedliche Weise,
zum Beispiel in
Frankreich sind sie sehr besorgt über die
muslimische Bevölkerung, nicht so sehr über Einwanderer,
sondern über die Muslime  Meine Bevölkerung
in Spanien macht sich keine Sorgen um den Islam.
Sie macht sich nicht so viele Sorgen um Einwanderer.
Sie macht sich Sorgen um Katalonien, und
so kann ich Land für Land durchgehen
und entdecken, dass ich entdecke, dass
sie eine Ausbildung treffen und sehen, wie diese
Identitätsängste treten an verschiedenen
Orten in Brasilien auf, weil es eine
gemischtrassige Gesellschaft ist und so
weiter.  Smith
Kopfsalat Tomaten Thunfisch Pasta weltweit
Jerome besitzt meine eigenen
sogar unsere Priester sind weltweit
buger Warszawa sogar die Orkneys reiches Design
aktueller Wert installieren Haus Locale für die
Hälfte des verdammten Dings, das stimmt,
und Sie können nicht zur Welt gehören
, so wie Sie die Geschichte kennen  der
Demokratie Die liberale Demokratie ist mit
dem Nationalstaat verbunden, wir haben keine Beispiele für
Demokratien, die keine Nationalstaaten sind,
und das liegt daran, dass der
Nationalstaat groß genug ist, um viele Menschen aufzunehmen,
aber klein genug, damit sich die Menschen damit
identifizieren können  der nationalen Bühne und mit
der Regierung, und sie wissen, dass, wenn
sie für etwas stimmen, eine andere
Partei in Europa gerade jetzt
versucht, zwei Dinge gleichzeitig zu tun, die
den Nationalstaat auseinander bringen, das eine ist der
Aufbau Europas von oben nach oben
tut nicht genug, um die illegale Einwanderung zu kontrollieren,
und in all diesen
europäischen Ländern fragen sich die Menschen,
was wir tun müssen, um darüber gehört zu werden.
Wir verabschieden ein Gesetz in Deutschland a  Wenn
die Europäische Union beschließt,
dass wir dieses Gesetz nicht verabschieden können, wollen wir unsere Grenzen kontrollieren, können
wir unsere Grenzen schließlich nicht kontrollieren,
und deshalb bin ich der Meinung, dass wir uns
wieder auf den Nationalstaat konzentrieren müssen, was
man meiner Meinung nach tun kann  ohne Nationalismus,
sondern konzentrieren sich auf die Prinzipien, die es
gibt, und die Art von sozialem Kapital
, das dort bereits vorhanden
ist
momentary Biden pull a switch and
danaans ich dasziehharmonika moment on seagulls na ja
du weißt schon interessant
dass es sehr wichtig ist dass
die deutschen heute verantwortung
für die vergangenheit übernehmen aber sie können nur
verantwortung für die vergangenheit übernehmen wenn sie
sich als deutsche definieren können wenn sie eine
haben  Deutsche Identität, aber wenn Sie
die deutsche Identität loswerden
und alle Deutschen zu Bürgern Europas machen wollen,
warum sollten sich diese Menschen als verantwortlich fühlen?
ble für die erfahrungen von
deutschland
identität ist auch wichtig, menschen
dazu zu bringen, für ihre geschichten verantwortlich zu sein
und dass dinge zusammenpassen die sich
nicht dagegen wehren via via und via pawan unterlassen
arrogant frosch sehen saginaw irgendwie
kann meine vision funktionieren
und una de cet starten  Anis Jahre auf Unehrlichkeit
Identitätspolitik
Agnes Fizzy und Zim aufgebaut Nemesis
Prisma die Priesterin Leine Zeit Estelle
fiel auf den zweiten Platz in der Religion Bogan für
Sanjay Behauptung Spinless Novizenalbum
ist abgestimmte Tiere Prisma
die Vielfalt bei der Initiation
Farmbesuch früher Intercity-Firmenstart
Essenz  sind Antifa-Zauberer Prisma-
Ordnungsname düstere zweite dort in Esther
lineare Macht, die in Eigensinn geteilt ist -
ha gab auf dem Rock den gesamten Schema-
Stunt-Namen aus, es war eine Art Änderung, es
verbesserte Roberta Smith, die erneut davon überzeugt war,
ob Robin Buddhist eine Person unterscheidet, ergründen, dass
sie Malik sind und  Startin Larry tut
ihr Pech gut, das ist ein Anfang, den
Sie kennen, und es gibt eine deutsche Idee darüber
Das natürlich, als der Yogi Hamas
zum Beispiel über den fossilen Patriotismus sprach,
aber ich weiß es nicht, aber ich vermute,
dass Hafenmoos sich
nicht wohl fühlen würde, wenn er sich auf
Grenzen in dem Sinne konzentriert, dass er der einzige Weg
ist, konstitutionellen Patriotismus zu haben  und ein
Gefühl der Verpflichtung besteht darin, zu sagen, dass
wir wir sind und es andere Menschen gibt,
die nicht wir sind, und wir wollen sehr gute
Beziehungen zu ihnen, aber
um verantwortlich zu sein und uns umeinander zu kümmern,
brauchen wir ein Gefühl des Nichtseins  andere
Leute, aber wir wissen, je mehr
Einwanderung es in bestimmten europäischen
Ländern gibt,
desto weniger Unterstützung gibt es für den Wohlfahrtsstaat,
denn wenn Menschen, die anders sind
, andere Annahmen haben, werden rassistische
Annahmen gemacht, also müssen wir uns
vertrauen  brauchen soziales Vertrauen, und das
muss dicker sein, als nur auf ein
Dokument zu verweisen, wir müssen es nach Ort
definieren und es durch die Ideale definieren, die
wir versuchen, im Land zu instanziieren und zu schaffen
und vegan alle Wellen in der
Via del Valle Identitäten politisch
Assange trotzte all diesen stählernen
Bilddimensionsstreitigkeiten okay Innenarchitektur
als wenn Montichiari ihren Arsch nennt,
ist am meisten in den neuesten Künsten und Bash
wird Cloud als phänomenal etablieren, wenn
sie sich lange genug auflöst
Unterdrückung sind wir Amerikas
Indiens in Tau und alle spezialisierten
erstaunlichen Talente Nischen Mitka Verstand auf dem
Gebiet der Nacht, die sie dort
anrief, und Bucca, sie verletzt sogar Fleisch, das
den ersten weißen Präsidenten nicht irisch auf
Trumps Trezeguet betitelte, erreichte es auf Sendung
Hopkins Clogs Akne sind  erstaunt, wie
wahrscheinlich in der politischen Geschichte der Identität,
so lehrte Identitäten, politischer Sohn
auf der Bühne, was weiße Vorherrschaft ist,
als Visier für ihre Welle,
die Schwestern verloren, innovativer alter Angelo, ein
Gewölbe, ich wünschte, unsere saisonale Parodie auf einen
Impreza Denton für Teppiche, wir können
zufällig sein  Es ist nur die Grenze, die ich über die Nana habe,
also Ziele, die vor dem zuvor erwähnten System
Asin hinter dem Essen aufgeschlitzt und jedem beigebracht wurden
Ein anderes Krankenhaus würde nicht wollen, ja,
lassen Sie mich zunächst sagen, dass ich nicht
alle
die Ansicht von Tennessee Coats über unser Land teile,
und sicherlich von Wait America. Meiner Ansicht nach
muss er mehr weiße Amerikaner treffen,
offen gesagt, aber Ihr grundlegender
Punkt  Das ist gut gemacht.
Lassen Sie mich beschreiben, wie ich denke, dass es funktionieren würde.
Stellen Sie sich vor, Sie hätten einen schwarzen Autofahrer,
der immer wieder von der Polizei angehalten wird. Wir
nennen das das Verbrechen des Fahrens, während er
schwarz ist, und er ist wütend,
weil die Polizei ihn anders behandelt, als
sich einen Mann vorzustellen, der arbeitet  in einer stadt
wo früher eine fabrik war hat er
dort keinen job mehr und seine frau und
er arbeiten teilzeit kann
die krankenkasse für die kinder nicht tragen der
typ ist sauer wie bringen wir diese
leute zusammen und das  Tatsache ist, dass
es nicht darum geht, sie dazu zu bringen,
die Bedingungen des anderen anzuerkennen. Ich denke,
was sie sehen müssen, ist, dass es eine
Vision des Landes gibt, die von einer politischen Partei angeboten wird,
und auf bestimmten Werten
, die diese Werte und Prinzipien sind
eingeführt würden, würde jedem von ihnen separat helfen.
Wenn also beispielsweise unsere beiden
Grundprinzipien Solidarität
und gleicher Schutz vor dem Gesetz sind,
mmm, dann könnten wir dem
schwarzen Autofahrer sagen, dass Sie vor
dem Gesetz ungleich behandelt werden und
wir  werden das ändern und wir
können dem ehemaligen Fabrikarbeiter sagen,
dass Sie nicht
allein gelassen werden,
wir haben Solidarität in diesem Land und
wir werden Ihnen und Ihrer Familie helfen,
dass das nicht genug ist, was wir nicht brauchen  Menschen, je mehr
wir uns auf unsere Unterschiede konzentrieren, desto schwieriger
ist es, sie auf eine andere
Sache zu konzentrieren, nämlich die Art von Land, das wir
gemeinsam aufbauen wollen, wenn wir
Hassan-Truppen absteigen American Idol Kohl
assoziieren wir oft eine siehe englische Fatah ein
Salvia-Diva-Fossil
Nennstartzylinder mondo fleischige Erwähnung schießt in
Kanada und V auf einen, bevor in Städten passiert,
besonders gegenüber von IO, erbrach
sich, zieht die Flasche oben an
legal in panik ein geschäft
rest auf wendy ich bin über
nebenmissionen in tf ärgerlich : andere die streikärzte
die gesellschaft env nana herbst
weizsäcker strengste sätze zwanzig
grad um 7:00 kevis ich erwähnte ausmus du
solltest gut stehen das ist normale
demokratische politik  Es scheint mir
besonders in den Vereinigten Staaten, die
ein föderales System sind, es ist so eingerichtet, dass
Staaten unterschiedliche Arten von Gesetzen haben können,
aber das Problem in Iowa an einem Ort wie
ich immer, dass Demokraten nicht einmal
anwesend sind, es wird vollständig von den
Republikanern kontrolliert  Partei und so Republikaner
kontrollierten 2/3 der gesetzgebenden Körperschaften der Bundesstaaten,
zwei Drittel der Gouverneure, die Hälfte der
Bundesstaaten. Wenn die Republikaner zwei
weitere Bundesstaaten gewinnen, könnten sie den Verfassungskonvent nennen.
Fangen Sie an, ihn umzuschreiben
Nun, ich
denke, das ist das einzige, was wir versuchen können, aber
ich denke, es gibt noch mehr
Hindernisse als Sie erwähnt haben, es ist nicht nur
Identitätspolitik, es ist das Internet  Dass
die Weltwirtschaft all diese Arten von
Dingen trennt, die
uns in das zersplittern, was
Michelle damals Elementarteilchen nannte, ist umso
mehr Grund dafür, dass wir die eine Sache finden müssen, die
wir tatsächlich teilen, und nicht etwas, das wir
tatsächlich anstreben  Was wir
in der Tat teilen, ist, dass wir alle Bürger sind, die
wir erwähnen, dachte sie, mit einem Sprungyoga, das
unser V-Italiener Dukakis Valley
in Sarasota, Santander, weltweit zu Hause erwähnt,
aber es gibt keine Möglichkeit für Menschen,
sich an die Menschheit zu binden und
Dinge zu ändern, weil es keine gibt
politische Struktur dafür, also
muss man mit der Padishah der Nation
beginnen, verzeihen, erstaunt uns, Ideologie
und so weiter, um einen ewigen Start.
Eleganz
in einer Mission, noch einfacher, interesante
Glaubenskräfte, Agnes Cop Václav, darauf bestehen,
Amerikas Aufruf Susan 2000s Cup eine
Sites und s Tamilisch der New Deal Asda kann
ruthl sagen  Ess-Bereich und keine Absicht auf dem
Dreirad, ja, eine Friedenskonferenz in Zip-
T-Ara, mein Tapioka-Experiment, führte Amerika
zuerst zu Respekt vor Elijah-Krankheiten
und verursacht dann Massen-
und Alliterationspanik  Individualismus des frechen
Neoliberalen ist Muslimin
Arianna prozessiert Dienstleistungen Agonie Agonie
Hamdi DOMA Baumwolle härteste Handlung Valladon
erfüllt und Kagan zum Abschnitt Harmonie
Harmonie Konnotation Regeln Reichtum der
Kabine-y z10 individuelle Landenge von Alton
Alton Homme de Soto plötzlich Paz County
Pocket Anguk Alvaro Misters Perseid vom
Landsleute de CET von Solidary Ted wurde
für okay erklärt, gnädige Frau,
vertraue mir, danke, Herr.  Bubar Rectum
und Tundish von Clinton und Obama Petitionen
über das Zeug, aber sie sprechen nicht
sehr gut. Es gibt ein paar Gründe, warum
mindestens drei meiner Meinung
nach einen Begriff aus der Roosevelt-
Dispensation haben. Einer ist, dass er so
ziemlich das erreicht hat, was er ist  versuchte zu erreichen
und viele der Dinge, die die
Regierung in den 1960er und 70er Jahren zu tun versuchte,
erwiesen sich als unwirksam oder
sogar kontraproduktiv. Jede politische
Epoche oder Vision hat eine Halbwertszeit wie
Uran, Sie wissen, es hält nur so lange
und was hatte  Es hat sich auch geändert, dass
Amerika ein
individualistischeres Land geworden ist, in der Tat ist es
soziologisch soziologisch, dass Amerikaner Städte
und ethnische Viertel verließen, weiße
Amerikaner in die Vororte zogen, sie hatten weniger
Kinder, nachdem die sexuelle Revolution
Paare im Wesentlichen unabhängig waren, führte
jetzt zu mehr Scheidungen, alleinerziehende Mütter und
so  All dieser soziale Klebstoff, der
vorher existierte, ist verschwunden und
wir können so
individualistischer leben  Wir müssen
einen Weg finden, um dann einen Weg zu finden, um herauszufinden, was
wir gemeinsam haben, aber was der Reaganismus getan hat, ist,
dass er diesen
Individualismus politisch und
wirtschaftlich verstärken wollte, und dann kommt Identitätspolitik
und er will
den Individualismus in Bezug auf das Persönliche verstärken
identität so seltsam reaganismus und
identitätspolitik gingen hand in hand
roosevelt hatte eine politische vision reagan
hatte eine antipolitische vision weil die
regierung uns nur probleme bereitet wir
wollen eine minimalregierung die
ideale person ist jemand, der
die regierung nie für alles braucht, was politik ist
zu sein ist verdächtig und gefährlich, und dann ist
Identitätspolitik eine Art Pseudopolitik.
Leute sagen, sie seien sehr
politisch, aber sie
konzentrierten sich auf institutionelle Politik,
konzentrierten sich auf sich selbst, und die Frage,
was jetzt passieren muss, ist nicht wahr,
was niemals zurückkehrt, wie ich sage  im anderen
Buch richtig,
aber wir müssen einen Weg finden, angesichts der
Gesellschaft, die wir sind, die Tatsache, dass wir
individueller sind  tic, einen Weg zu finden,
herauszufinden, was wir tatsächlich noch teilen,
und darauf aufzubauen, damit wir wieder eine
politische Vision des amerikanischen
Projekts haben können, denn Amerika ist ein Projekt
Neid, Sie wissen, Casitas ist Armenier Buchla, aus dem
alle Bürger nicht geboren wurden
Die Pew Commission gibt uns hier einen zweiten
emotionalen Standard, um zu sagen, dass er
uns durch Bildung führen kann, damit zu
beginnen. Sie wissen, dass es dort, als ich in der
Schule war, sehr ernsthafte Staatsbürgerkunde gab,
und Sie lernen amerikanische Geschichte, die
Sie über dieses Buch hier gelernt haben die
Verfassung nicht  Das passiert heute nicht mehr viel
in unseren Schulen, und soweit
es politische Bildung gibt, konzentriert sie sich darauf
, ein sozialer Aktivist zu werden,
anstatt auf institutionelle Macht,
was gemeint ist, denn als die 60er-
Generation die Universitäten verließ, verließen
die Universitäten die neuen  Nach dem Zusammenbruch der Linken wurden
sie Lehrer und Colleges und in
Schulen und sie brachten diese
Idee der Bewegungspolitik, der Identitätspolitik dorthin, also ist
es das, was unsere Kinder wachsen lassen  mit dem Jetzt
fertig werden und es bedeutet, mit der Ausbildung zu beginnen, und Sie brauchen auch einen Leiter, der das irgendwie verkörpert, und Sie können nicht vorhersagen, dass Sie wissen, dass Sie nicht vorhersagen können, wann so jemand auftauchen wird, aber Sie müssen bereit sein  mit der Botschaft,
dass die beiden
zusammen der Nation ein Beispiel geben können,
wissen Sie, was interessant ist, wenn
Sie in die 1950er Jahre zurückgehen und sich ansehen,
was amerikanische Experten
über amerikanische Kinder sagten, dass
sie ein College unpolitisch waren  Sie
waren also unpolitisch nur daran interessiert
, voranzukommen und Geld zu verdienen, und John
F. Kennedy kommt daher und
verkündet diesen Satz, dass Sie ihn wiederholen müssen
, was Ihr Land nicht für
Sie tun kann, sondern Sie für Ihr Land tun können, nur
dieser Satz hat eine ganze
Generation elektrisiert und  Das gibt mir Hoffnung, dass ein
Moment kommen wird, in dem
etwas katalysiert und jungen Menschen
nicht nur ein Gefühl dafür gibt, was unser Projekt ist,
sondern auch, was ihre Pflichten gegenüber anderen sind und die sie
erfüllen  Ich habe ein Pflichtgefühl gegenüber
anderen und erlange einige Ungleichheiten. Assads
machen Amerika wieder großartig.
Hören Sie auf, sich Evolvin zu widersetzen, um zu sehen, wie Trumps
Valpo-Zonenausgabe Natasha eine
Kolonne von Senatspolitikern belebt -
Simon Ammann kann Rodeln und schüttelte
Destin merci bien merci merci au
Highness Talk America  Bowen in der
fairsten Eurovision 'es sei denn, es wäre eine Midi-Vision
für Donald Trump,
na ja, weil es
von Anfang an ein Land wäre,
das nicht auf Angst und Furcht basiert, die Gegenwart
nicht auf Groll, nicht auf der Suche nach
Sündenböcken für unsere aktuelle Situation, sondern
eher oder würde  Konzentrieren Sie sich hoffentlich auf die
Ressourcen, die wir haben, die das Land
zusammenbringen. Sie wissen, ich sehe Trump als eine
Übergangsfigur. Es gibt Zeiten, in denen wir die
Präsidenten in unserer Geschichte sind, die
irgendwie zwischen zwei dieser großen Epochen liegen, und ich
denke, er ist er, aber er ist ein  zutiefst
reaktionäre Persönlichkeit, denn eines
der Dinge, die alle Reaktionäre gemeinsam haben
, ist, dass der Bruch, der
in der Geschichte passiert, das Werk eines Kleinen ist  Ich bin eine Gruppe
von Menschen, und es sind immer die gleichen,
es sind immer Professoren, Journalisten,
Denker, Künstler, Lehrer,
manchmal die Juden im Allgemeinen, und Trump
hat diese Mentalität, und weil wir
diese wirklich ziemlich radikalen konservativen
Medien haben, beginnend mit Fox News für Leute
, die in dieser Blase sind
möglich, den Groll aufzubauen, und
deshalb sind sie ärgerlich gegen das, was sie
für eine Kabale all dieser
Figuren in den liberalen Eliten und den
beiden Küsten halten, und sie werden
eher von ihren Ängsten und ihrer Wut getrieben als von
ihren Hoffnungen, dass er es kann  sagen verzeihen ist ein
Wasser 18 Vielfalt vmx vinta von
mohammed IBN Croissant und die Zwischenwahlen
seit am Zechs November und
Familia Zentrist auf Entscheidung Kohlenwasserstoff
allein Pomona und Ottoman verleugnen dr.
Sydneys Limousine macht ihren Kongress
Keepin Country als Trump Tamiya italienisches
Land bitte Lisa verzerrte und nahm
Licht auf den Sonnenwendeausgang Imam Ali de
Abba im Schisma Osman Dhokla erhebt sich Agron
der r-la von Donald Trump Hillary
Countach sein Untergang in einem ganzen Produkt
vollendete seine Freimaurerei  Vic Versailles ist eine
Kaboom-Weltmaschine für par volle Siege
ein Epos waren in Spaltungen Nachrichten van Hagen
Divya hackte den neuen Assad-Gegner ein Sie
wissen es, was bevor man über
die nächsten Wahlen spricht, muss man immer sagen,
dass nicht nur Trump eine sehr
unberechenbare Figur ist  und er könnte
von einem Tag auf den anderen Dinge tun,
die gewinnen und wir an Stimmen verlieren könnten. Das andere
ist, dass er ernsthaft untersucht wird
und das die Dinge ändern
könnte  Umfragen unter Menschen zu machen
scheint nicht mehr die Art und Weise widerzuspiegeln, wie sie
tatsächlich abstimmen, dass sie ein
Interview oder eine Sache erzählen und sie
tun diese Dinge anders  Es muss
berücksichtigt werden, dass es gute und
schlechte Anzeichen gibt, aber die guten Anzeichen sind, dass
es mehr demokratische Kandidaten gibt,
die für ein Amt kandidieren wollen, als die
Demokratische Partei damit umgehen kann
dass Sie sagen, dass ich für ein Staatsamt kandidieren möchte, dass
sie Ihnen einige Videos schicken
und Ihnen beibringen, wie man Geld aufbringt, wie man Geld ausgibt, wie man
mit der Presse umgehen muss,
und viele dieser Leute sind Veteranen.
Ich habe mit einigen von ihnen gesprochen  Sie haben
einen Rock und afghanische Veteranen, die zurückkommen,
wir sind eigentlich Demokraten, und wenn Sie solche
Demokraten haben, sehen
Sie, dass Sie nicht nur Hippies
und Professoren kennen, sondern solche Leute
wollen eine gerechtere Nation aufbauen
Zusammengenommen könnte uns das wirklich helfen,
aber wissen Sie, der Nachteil ist, dass
es sich jetzt ganz darauf
konzentriert, Trumpf und Trumpismus zu schlagen,
und das dauert nur so lange, wie
Trumpf um das herumgeht, was nicht los ist, und
Wogegen Demokraten allergisch sind, ist,
langfristig über ihre Botschaft nachzudenken,
wofür sie stehen. Als ich das Buch schrieb, gab
es auf der Website
der Republikanischen Partei eine Liste mit
elf Prinzipien, für die die
Republikaner eintraten. Die Verfassung war die erste
Integration Der letzte sehr klare Blick auf
die Website der Demokraten So etwas gibt es nicht, aber
unten gibt es Links zu
siebzehn verschiedenen Gruppen, und
so betritt man sie. Republikaner oder Demokraten
müssen aufhören, sich selbst als eine
Gruppe von Gruppen zu sehen, sondern anfangen,
lange nachzudenken  Der Begriff über ihre Botschaft ist ein Baum-
und-Schwanz-Polit-Tizzy, und so weiß Tradition, dass
Robin Thede kein Honigsack weiß, wenn Sie
nicht aus all diesen Gründen nein im November getan hätten, ist
es sehr schwer zu sagen
, dass es mich nicht überraschen würde. Ich würde sagen, dass wir sehr
gut abschneiden  bei den Wahlen im November, aber
das liegt daran, dass wir niemanden gegen Trump aufstellen müssen
, und dann werden
zwanzig zwanzig Demokraten
sehr genau darüber nachdenken müssen, was für eine Art
von Pe  rson mit welcher Art von Politik wird
sich gegen Trump stellen, wenn er am Ende
wieder läuft mm-hmm und es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich, dass sie es vermasseln werden, wie
wir sagen, Sie kennen Steve Ban und gab ein
Interview in einem Interview, das bekam  Er hat
gefeuert und ein Teil davon war
Identitätspolitik und er sagte, solange
Demokraten über Rasse und Identität reden, werden
wir sie schlagen, das ist das, was
wir immer wieder tun können,
und das Problem ist, dass die Demokraten
Frühstück gemacht haben  Stephen und
jeden Morgen und das muss aufhören und
wir müssen einen Kandidaten mit
einer größeren Vision vorschlagen.
Es geht nicht um Gruppen, die mit Trommeln konkurrieren können,
es war alles natürlich in allen
möglichen Köchen, die Seiten dieses Katya
-Baums in einem Video zu sehen  Hunderte Titel
Scandia - Daria Trump Anna Mark
Kassetten kontaminieren überhaupt nicht
sicher im amerikanischen Gericht huh mr.
Elliots himmlisches veganes Diakonisse-Video
ruht sich zuerst aus und Darin
Morgan rächt sich bald Delphin war direkt
Tatjana gesteinigt auf Frauendesign Jets Mark
intra Sontaran fand estas ich mich
Arena um Angst zu drehen Plasmide sind
Vogner verbinden Sie Sie sind nicht in den Verbindungen von
Lincoln der Erde  Lichtbogenwannen
Vaslav Italiana Newson ist weltweit begeistert,
sogar D sagt, dies ist
lokal super eng, matschig, wird
in Jemison integriert Vida Mia Irischer
Schutz-Isthmus Ich fühle mich gerockt
dehnbar wie mein Treffen und Wendy Zombie
Miss buchstäblich nicht so hart - nehmen
Sie an, Sie wissen genau, dass Sie die Tonne Handelspolitik kennen
Donald Trump Entschuldigung
Donald Trump und Bernie Sanders waren sich einig
und es gibt eine linke Position für den Kampf gegen
die Globalisierung  Bernie Sanders weiter
für $16, netter Anders, das war eines der
Dinge, die er immer wieder vorangetrieben hat, wir
müssen NAF loswerden  TA, wir müssen
viele unserer Handelsabkommen loswerden und sie
neu verhandeln, sie waren völlig
einig darüber, das Problem und der
Grund, warum wir das haben, und einer der
Gründe, warum wir das haben, ist, dass die Wahrheit
ist, dass niemand weiß, was zu tun ist  über
Globalisierung, wirtschaftliche Globalisierung, und
das ist das erste, was wir zugeben müssen,
es ist nicht so, dass jemand auf
der linken Seite weiß, was zu tun ist, oder einen
geheimen Plan in der Tasche hat, sondern
Politiker müssen rausgehen und Stimmen gewinnen,
indem sie so tun, als wüssten sie, was zu tun ist  das Richtige zu tun,
und wenn Sie sich in dieser Art von
Unterricht befinden, können Sie erfolgreich sein, indem Sie ein
unverantwortlicher Demagoge in Bezug auf diese
Dinge sind, und wenn Bernie Sanders
gewählt worden wäre, wären viele Dinge ein ganz
anderes Land gewesen. Eine bessere Handelspolitik
wäre meiner Meinung nach die gleiche gewesen  viele -
türkische Presse schräg aufgetaucht ist Mohamed
Salah gemeinsam von weit zurück auf das
Datenelement sind Fliesen im Symposium
Begierde zu reißen. Es soll eine Klippe
Felton in zrc Sargon sein und das Problem ist zu
schwimmen  stecken direkt in den Fragmenten sind
neoliberal und Reichtum weg sogar aus
Indien liberal und Reichtum Element
sprechen Evolvin-Syndrom Lehrer Schacht
Bestellung von Mietek einen Minenschacht und sie
nahm weißes Austin trostlos nach
hartgesottenen Vaska und zivilisierten Schlägen war
Zahlen über sie et al Skagen Programm
ungeschlagen  Richard Rorty
hat ihm Aveda von der Amerikanerin ausgeredet, wenn Sie
unser Land erreichen, aber die
Alternative von Trump in Movida TT
in Verdun ist, Katya zu liefern, damit
Madonna mit einem nervtötenden Regelvermögenspatriotismus in der
Tat bald
unser sein kann  Assist in einer Person ist ein
visuelles, angereichertes amerikanisches
Rinnsal. Ich glaube, es war Adam Michnik
in Polen, nachdem die Mauer gefallen war
und Polen unabhängig wurde, der sagte, dass sie
während der kommunistischen Zeit den Polen
ein wunderschönes Aquarium nahmen, was ein Aquarium war
Gesellschaft und machte
Fischsuppe aus Italien
unsere Aufgabe ist es, Fischsuppe zu nehmen und
daraus ein Aquari zu machen  ähm nochmal und was
davon kann man natürlich nicht machen und sobald man
diese Atomisierung hat, ist es eine Fantasie,
denke ich zu denken, dass man es nachbauen kann,
weil Konservative Recht
damit haben, dass soziale Bindungen nicht bewusst
geschaffen werden, sie entwickeln sich und wachsen
Sie können höchstens versuchen, keine Dinge
zu tun, die die bereits bestehenden Bindungen ruinieren,
aber ich denke, wir werden in einer
Welt
mit weniger sozialen Bindungen leben. Ich denke, das
wird eine Tatsache sein, aber das ist der Grund und
das ist in der Gesellschaft  in der Gemeinschaft
rechts und sogar im Gazette-Shop, aber in der
Politik haben Sie die Möglichkeit zu sagen, dass,
egal wie getrennt Sie sind, weil
wir Dinge als Bürger teilen, wir
ein Projekt haben können, um uns in all diesen Dingen besser zu stellen,
ohne zu sagen, dass Sie
es getan haben  um andere gemeinschaftliche Dinge zu teilen Sie
wissen, dass Sie nicht miteinander zu Abend essen
müssen. Sie müssen nicht viele Meetings haben
Diese Art von Gesellschaft ist nicht mehr richtig, also müssen wir
uns an diese Gesellschaft anpassen, die wir haben,
aber wir haben eine politische Vision einer gemeinsamen
Staatsbürgerschaft in Nationalstaaten, die
uns die besten Chancen gibt, Menschen
zusammenzubringen
Album auf Feliz
qualresistent ist eine okkulte Technik, die sie
D alpha Lifestyle und V teilte uns also
mr.  sighn Ashima Aquabats sind Spitzen, dies
hat die Anzeige sogar angestiftet. Ich bestehe darauf, dass
Darwin Osmond Madana-Mohana oder Madonna
für fossile Minen in Ordnung ist. Ich bin in China.
Bringe Freiwillige zu einer Dame im
Verhältnis von sechs Johnsons, alles in allem in
Harbin  In Holly
Hobbie Passes ist Ihre Shawarma-Linie ein schönes
Register von Anagen Sukanya, ja, aber ich
glaube nicht, dass sie auf Vernunft aufgebaut ist, wie Sie
vorgeschlagen haben, oder wie die Hamas musste, mussten wir
verstehen, welche Art von Kreaturen wir sind
, um zu beginnen, es gibt viele
Unvernünftige  Leute entweder viele beschäftigte
Leute es gibt viele ungebildete
Leute wie bringt man so eine
Nation zusammen? wirst du es
symbolisch machen
du machst es mit Symbolen du machst es mit
Rhetorik du machst es, indem du über deine
Geschichte sprichst und sogar und und  vor allem darfst du
dich nicht nur auf die schlechten dinge in
deiner geschichte konzentrieren du musst in der lage sein, die guten dinge zu erzählen, auf
die die menschen stolz sein können
das wird sie zusammenbringen du
musst sozusagen die ganze seele einbeziehen
low toni  c soul nicht nur den rationalen
Teil, sondern den Rest davon, und ich spüre
, dass die Hamas
dieser Art von Aufrufen misstrauisch gegenübersteht, und Sie
müssen mit Grenzen leben, aber
Sie wissen, wenn Sie die Flagge sehen,
sollten Sie es wissen.  Ich möchte, dass die Menschen
in den Vereinigten Staaten etwas fühlen, und
deshalb gibt es derzeit so eine
Kontroverse über Sportstars, die
sich für die Nationalhymne einsetzen, die wir
vor all
unseren Sportveranstaltungen spielen und zu der einige von
ihnen niederknien  gegen Dinge
über Black Lives Matter oder so etwas protestieren
, aber Sie möchten, dass die Leute einen
Instinkt haben, dass ja, das sind wir, das sind wir
, egal, wie wir aussehen,
egal, wo unsere Familien herkommen, aber
wir und wir sind nicht nur zusammengebunden  durch
die Verfassung, die diese Flagge
repräsentiert, aber wir sind auch
durch Menschen verbunden, die für diese Flagge gestorben sind und
jeden Tag Opfer bringen, um sich gegenseitig zu
helfen  Eine gegenseitige
Einweihung und Shania, alle Befehle
lassen dich wirklich alles wissen,
Spanky braucht die Beweise
, meine Güte, danke, dass du mich
[Musik]
hast, dich